remember resident evil 4's original
gamecube case the one that said only
four in the corner it's hard to imagine
now considering the game has been ported
every which way to the nokia phone and
back but despite its acclaimed status
all its ports and the modest visual
facelift it has received over the years
one thing remains woefully unchanged and
firmly cements resident evil 4 in 2005
when it was originally released those
damned tank controls even the wii
edition the best port of the game i must
say was shackled by its rigid movement
that is until resident evil 4 vr which
presents the game in its best light
since its original release playing
through the action horror classic on the
oculus quest 2 has given me a feeling
i've wanted since first finishing
resident evil 4 16 years ago on the
gamecube the sense of experiencing it
for the first time all over again and
that feeling is downright
awesome
from the ground up the game has been
meticulously recreated in unreal engine
4 in uncanny detail to fully function in
vr and the result is so impressive it's
nothing short of magic from upscale
textures to sound effects and animations
resinual 4 can now be seen quite
literally through an entirely new lens
stepping into the shoes of protagonist
and pretty boy leon s kennedy on a
mission to save the president's daughter
has never felt cooler nor has the horror
representation of eastern europe ever
felt more
frightening nearly everything has been
updated to accommodate vr your equipment
is now accessible on your physical body
shoulder for your knife chest for a
grenade and utility belt for weapon
magazines this means physically loading
your gun and cocking it before firing it
off unsheathing your knife to break open
crates or pulling the pin on a grenade
and letting it cook before tossing at
the feet of some gennados and performing
nearly every action made me feel like a
total president-daughter-saving badass
vr has unanimously excelled at first
person combat and it shines
exceptionally well in resident evil 4 vr
shooting dynamite out of someone's hands
juking out of the way of a thrown
hatchet unloading a submachine gun with
one hand and pulling out a pistol with
the other to show off enemies next me
felt so
satisfying
even just opening cabinets was an oddly
thrilling new way to interact with a
world i know so well pumping a shotgun
and squeezing the trigger point-blank in
an enemy's face followed with a
blood-drenched explosion of their skull
only for tentacles to erupt from its
neck up close and personal in vr is gasp
inducing and even when i was shaken with
anxiety there is no denying i had a
smile from ear to ear while combat is
far more versatile in ways the original
never could be like duel wielding a
knife and a pistol or even a shotgun and
a submachine gun don't be fooled the
odds still stagged against me and each
onslaught of gonados felt harrowing
resident evil 4 vr still manages to
capture the tension and stress of the
original very well and honestly dual
wielding and guns blazing is rarely a
route worth taking as it can be a waste
of resources but there's no denying it
got me out of some dire situations as
mentioned actions that were once a
simple button press now require
physicality from the player like opening
cabinets drawers toggling switches
turning door keys and solving puzzles
it's a little touch and not an entirely
remarkable idea for a vr title but it
remains effective in elevating the
residential 4 experience being able to
open drawers or slowly ease a door to
see what's around the corner has a huge
impact on immersion and helps the game
feel like a new and modern experience
even saving on a typewriter now involves
physically pressing the mechanical keys
of an early 20th century typewriter and
it is such a simple delight some things
are locked to button presses and
rightfully so like jumping out of a
window or hopping over a barrier and in
these cases it switches the third person
for me someone who experiences minor
motion sickness i was grateful for this
but your mileage may vary you can also
opt to remain in first person thanks to
an option found in the settings seeing
resident evil 4's iconic enemies and
environments up close emphasizes the
feeling of experiencing it for the first
time again i was able to notice detail
before like enegonado's face its eyes
vacant and googly with their mouth
slightly ajar and crooked it made an
already unsettling enemy feel far more
eerie and intrusive environments i had
seen a dozen times before in my previous
console playthroughs felt all the more
engrossing it took more time to observe
the haunting victorian paintings in the
castle or that cart filled with corpses
by the farm just looking at the dirty
water in the well as i reached into it
to pick up treasure made me want to wash
my hands in real life as for
accessibility the options are plentiful
it ranges from full motion to standing
sitting down and whether you're right or
left-handed there's also different modes
of interaction such as immersive which
puts all the gear and weapons on your
physical body or comfort mode where your
arsenal can be switched and rotated
through with a few button presses
additionally there's a wealth of options
to tweak and finesse your ideal playing
experience i played in immersive mode
standing with teleportation movement for
the entirety of my 13 hour playthrough
and rarely did i experience any
discomfort but not everything works as
well as it's intended counter moves in
particular is a mechanic i abandoned
using early in my playthrough counter
moves like kicks and supluxes can be
performed after stunning an enemy by
shooting them in the knees or in the
face in these occurrences i found myself
clumsily fumbling to get close enough to
an enemy to press the button and
initiate it often completely missing the
window of chance and thrusting myself
into harm's way unintentionally the
action felt clumsy and unintuitive
compared to the physical motion of
everything else so i eventually just
stopped using it some boss fights also
don't translate smoothly into vr del
lago the swamp boss fight in particular
proved to be a point of frustration for
me controlling the boat while being
pulled along by the giant beast and
having to simultaneously load a harpoon
gun and fire it was a lot to manage it's
something that worked well on console
but having the full motion of vr while
operating multiple things at once was a
little too disorienting to my surprise
however parts i dreaded returning to
from the original specifically the
game's final action focus act were
actually improved thanks to vr
traditionally considering ra4's original
rigid movements and lack of cover system
fighting off the game's final military
armed foes was usually a slow slog to
run around a corner only to get a shot
in before scurrying away pacing the
original game became disjointed and kind
of out of character in these moments but
in vr the action is amplified thanks to
being able to physically duck around
corners take cover shoot through
openings in the wall or toss grenades
out it felt amazing and made getting in
a shootout with crossbow wielding
gatling guns shooting axe throwing goons
a total blast
this exhilarating implementation of
combat makes the lack of mercenaries
mode however all the more apparent
playing re4's action segments through vr
lenses left me wanting to see how its
action horror can translate in the
arcade style experience of mercenary so
its absence is a minor letdown so
instead the moment the credits rolled i
began my second playthrough on new game
plus with plans to run through an
additional harder professional
difficulty mode there's no game i've
completed more times in my life than
residing before nor is there a game i've
purchased as many times but experiencing
it via a different format is an
astonishing experience bringing the 16
year old classic to vr doesn't just
reaffirm why it's a classic to begin
with but is now among the best vr games
on offer and it's evident that building
the game from the ground up was a true
labor of love residual 4 vr is an
essential game to have in your oculus
quest 2 library right alongside beat
saber and super hot it is a welcoming
version to newcomers that are vr capable
and most excitingly not only will
players get to experience resume 4 in a
new way that doesn't compromise the
original's greatness even with its
quarks but a new generation of players
will get to hear leon s kennedy's campy
one-liners and that's a prospect
i'm very excited about
[Music]
[Music]
foreign